amd's rx480 was the first sound of the
Polaris trumpet and it was about time a
card from the red team that appeared
competitive not by itself but when
crossfir as two RX 480s and Crossfire
will likely compete with a single GTX
1070 and at around the same price point
if you haven't yet seen my coverage of
the 480 you can check it out in the cart
above me amds told me they're sending
one to the studio so I expect to be able
to pit that thing head-to-head against
this r9390 lurking in the rig behind
behind me however for those Still
rocking those 1080p monitors I mean even
I do this one's a 1080p Ultra wide and
rx480 might be a bit overboard but what
about those of us looking for more
relaxed let's take things a little
slower graphics cards well AMD has two
solutions for you the rx470 and the RX
460 this video is covering the 470 but
if you're interested in the 460 you can
check it out in more detail in the card
above me so what's with this leaked info
first off I should disclose the fact
that these these data that you're about
to see are not confirmed could be
completely made up these people might
just be making up these these results
just for the sake of attention and if
that's the case shame on them but for
the sake of this video we will rely on
this data because this at this point is
all we have to go off of the source of
these benchmarks is Tweakers a Dutch
technology website they claim that AMD
has quote unquote released the bench
marks you're about to see but I'll let
you be the judge of that AMD themselves
haven't said much in regards to either
the 470 or the 460 save a few lines of
hype and a fancy debut of the card's
design and then we have two other cards
here which are pretty exciting as well
we have the RX 470 and the RX 460 the
470 is really focused on excellent
performance per watt so it's 2.8x over
the previous generation and you get full
HD experiences 1080p running 60 frames
per second gorgeous card we'll have many
many different versions of this from our
addin board partners and then we have
the 460 which is really focused on
Esports so I heard about all those
Esports fans in the audience this guy is
going to be the best card in the
industry less than 75 Watts cool fast I
think you're going to love these cards
so we're really excited about our new
technology here but without further Ado
here are the purported benchmarks
[Music]
okay so let's discuss what we just saw
the RX 470 is by no means a Powerhouse
and it was never meant to be however
what we can discern from these graphs is
that the 470 is a much better performer
obviously and then it's 270x and 370
counterparts starting with fire strike
the 470 received a score that was just
over 57% higher than the 270x at 9,90
versus
5,787 this also places the rx470 above
the r9380 and 380x and just under the
390 at
10,420 oh and did I mention at a price
tag substantially lower than all of them
in gamees Hitman ashes of the
singularity and OverWatch the 470 wiped
the floor with the 270x Ying
significantly higher frame rates across
the board all of this while maintaining
a much smaller thermal footprint at 110
Watts TDP versus the 27x is 180 it makes
sense now why the 470 reference card
only features a single six pin power
connector impressive performance and
efficiency from amd's Polaris 10 GPU now
at first at least from my personal point
of view the 470 appeared to be a distant
child of the 480 is longing for the
attention that the 40 will likely
receive thanks to its competitive price
point and performance however things
changed for me today after looking at
these benchmarks assuming that they're
relatively accurate here's what sealed
the deal for me the rx470 specifications
in all honesty aren't far off from the
480s either so it makes sense I made
accurate predictions about the 480s T
flop value right at 5.5 and I expect
right under five Tera flops of floating
Point performance for the 470 I'll say
4.8 for now memory bandwidth is also
slightly diminished at 224 GB per second
although it's unlikely you'll ever
notice this in gameplay now as for price
wccf tech and others are expecting the
470 to retail for around
$150 about the same price as a current
r7370 the 470s older sibling at this
price point and level of performance
we're looking at Double the performance
of the r7370 for the exact same price
1.83 times the performance to be exact
the same can be said in terms of the
r9270x as well I predict a great deal of
competition from the red team this year
as well as the next now fans of the
green I I hear you either of nvidia's
current flagships would blow these from
AMD out of the water but AMD hasn't
released their top tier card yet either
don't be so quick to judge just yet if
you liked what you've seen in this video
give it a thumbs up give it a thumbs
down if you feel the complete opposite
or if you hate everything about life be
sure to click subscribe button if you
haven't already stay tuned for future
AMD build here on the channel this is
science Studio thanks for learning with
us
[Music]